there's so much to talk about there's so
much going on with you right now oh
things you're a Broadway star your TV
story my philanthropy oh boy so much
gold I still can't dance that's the last
few months I guess last you've been for
you well it's been I mean I like to dive
into work so it's been a blessing in
that way I've been so happy to have so
many things to do and so many things
that I've been asked to do yeah it's you
know 20 years now in the business and to
be constantly given you know new
challenges and new things to sink my
teeth into that I can learn from I feel
very lucky but you know then those
things get finished and then those
things have to come out and you got to
go talk about all those things and
you're like oh I've got a lot of things
so you know it's a lot but but I feel
very very grateful for it all here we
are with your eighth studio album the
September 21st it was released and I was
listening to this morning out last night
bigger than us is my favorite thanks oh
thank you so much
and it's a romance of sadness there's
optimism in it as well languages there's
so much how would you describe his album
compared I guess the other one well I
mean I had the luxury of time when it
came to writing songs for this album you
know I made a musical theatre record and
then I went on Broadway for you yeah so
it's it's been since I can't believe it
but it's been since 2013 since I've
released original music that I've
written so I had a lot of life
experiences I had a lot of ideas ready
to go I had a lot of stuff that I wanted
to say and so so I mean these songs are
just a reflection of those experiences
and those sounds and inspirations that I
wanted to tap into this time around I
wanted it to be kind of along the lines
of how I made the first few records but
with a fresher approach and a fresher
sound and and I feel like I've grown as
a vocalist so I wanted to just you know
leave everything I had in the studio on
every song and yeah it came out you know
sometimes it's like pulling teeth but
this one really came out every session
came out exactly as I wanted but it was
a bit of a journey because I think you
know one point he called it exercising
but it's it's it's true because because
you know every time you're going into a
new album process and you're saying oh
okay I've got a hundred thirty second
snippets on my iPhone I'm gonna work
with these producers in my work for
maybe a couple writers we work with
before but a lot of things I want to say
and it's just rattling around in your
head
time is just in your head and you go
through process where it's not sounding
the way you want it to and and you're
yourself criticizing and you're thinking
maybe you know I think any project that
you haven't torn up the book and thrown
it out 20 times until you've gotten it
right probably wasn't worthwhile and so
I feel like that's kind of what happened
on this one and and it eventually once
you've you listened to that final mix
and that final master it's like yes
that's that's what I've heard in my head
for to hear crypts it is it's like a
huge like sonic weight off your
shoulders then we got it to where you
wanted it to be and every time I do it
and I release a new a new album into the
world I think I can I gotta wait a
minute to muse smoking the proverbial
cigarette you know and anything I'm
spent I gotta wait I gotta wait a while
till I do that again I don't think I
could do that ever again and then a
couple years later you're recharged and
ready to go again but this was also the
title bridges yeah there's a
significance to that you know coming up
with the titles challenging how do you
find a word or phrase it represents the
arc of what you were going through and
what the whole sonic of the record is
obviously having a song like bridge over
troubled water smart and the message of
that song kind of sparked an influence
as far as what I wanted the the overall
feeling of the record to be and I wrote
it during you know difficult times in
the world I wrote it during a time when
I felt very grateful that I was able to
cross a lot of bridges in my career and
and and juggle a lot of different things
and had been given the allowance by my
fans and the public to try things that I
hadn't done before and to kind of expand
my lane but then I thought to myself
also just I feel so privileged to be in
a position in music where in this very
divisive world I can look out an
audience and bring people together and I
can rant and rave on twitter twitter all
I want about it I feel and all that
political policies and things like that
but in music I have I have a really
privileged you know position to provide
some unity and so you know I was
thinking more bridges less walls let's
let's let's let's put that positive
spirit out there and that's the album is
to me that positive spirit and that's
what I wanted to have on there you know
that's what I loved about you the fact
that you use your voice even it's a
political stance you're you're having
that conversation with people and using
your Twitter flap oh yeah that's
important yeah and you getting a little
trouble sometimes doing that between us
free you know yeah unfollow yeah
I'm not asking people to buy my Twitter
account yeah so it's you know it's it's
it's a balance because you know I I
don't agree with the shut up in sing
mentality and think that whether you
sing or you do anything else for a
living everybody has the right to
express their their opinion but at the
same time you know the arts are a
universal language they are one of the
few things we have left in this world
that actually bring people together
beyond any of the things that we're told
divide us every single day on cable
right and so you know I will always
share my opinion I'll always share I'll
always be on the side of where I feel
the right side of history is but I also
feel that that the artistic side of me
has an opportunity and I think a you
know a duty to to bring people together
as much as possible because really I
think there are no shortage of opinions
out there ain't nobody's minds are being
changed yeah so might as well put a
little like the world yes love that your
music speaks to so many people - it's
emotional there you feel when you and
I'm assuming when you're on stage you
feel it so when you hear your music on
the radio or maybe when you're driving
your Mustang contrary to popular belief
you got emotion to do separate yourself
from your youth singing the songs I I'm
I think I'm probably not alone in saying
that I'm not my best audience when I'm
in it when I'm singing it when I'm on
stage when I'm recording it when I'm in
the process of the song and the voice
exiting my body I'm all in emotionally I
am all in I feel it the same the first
time as I do the 500th time but if I'm
just listening to it I am my own
harshest critic I think about I should
change that
yeah I have never been able to like sit
back and enjoy kind of kind of the same
way that a fan would you know but I
think that's similar I mean I've seen
some of my favorite actors in the world
squirm on talk-show couches when they
have to watch a clip you know and it
doesn't mean they weren't full in it
doesn't mean I'm gonna get nominated for
an Oscar it's just like it's just hard
it's hard to separate it is hard to say
I'm not like a fanboy of my own stuff I
wish I was like I wish I could go to
that place where I was like
let's have another listening party come
on I got our d'oeuvres I want you to
hear my stuff again you know I'm very
I'm actually very shy about presenting
it because it means so much to me and I
overthink things so I do self criticize
a bit but yeah but if other people once
you put it out in the world who's out of
your control and when people respond to
it just just reading through the
messages have gotten my last 48 hours
about all of it just makes my day it so
makes me so happy I love that talk about
a shy moma in that first pivotal moment
when you're on the stage with our
Canadian girl Celine Dion said Canada is
my reason for being David yeah think I'm
Canadian
like I appreciate you Arden thank you so
much and I would nothing would make me
happier but no it was a bit foster yeah
he believed you in you right from the
beginning what does it me to have him
part of your journey I mean it's it's
when I look back at the Stars it aligned
I didn't know when I was 17 that I would
lead to a big break that it would lead
to me sitting here now 20 years later I
I knew that David was a really big deal
and made some of the greatest music of
our generation I did not understand why
he was interested in me because it
wasn't you know I wasn't a pop singer at
that time you know I kind of had to grow
into that a little bit so you know why
is it why is he looking at this 17 year
old high school kid you know you're me
you're gonna have me go up there and
sing with Celine into rehearsal I
couldn't believe it I didn't have stars
in my eyes I wasn't thinking about
becoming a superstar I wanted to do
theater and act and stuff and but I
think any of us that have had the
opportunity to break through to that
other side of having that really big big
opportunity we can all thank one person
in our lives who gave us that big break
whether it's a David Foster or it's a mo
Austin or it's a Steven Spielberg or
whatever it is he was the guy that said
hey kid I think there's something
special and I'm willing to bet not
selling any records on it and I think
that's the important thing because I was
not a sure thing I was not the fad at
the moment and for him to say I don't
care if we break even or even lose money
I'm this is a passion for me and I want
to do this with you that's the way I
made my first album and that and it
resonated with people and so that's the
way I've decided to make every album
which is to say I'm not thinking about
you know
hits hits I'm not thinking about reviews
I'm just thinking does this give me
chills or not because we're all human
beings and maybe my fans will feel that
way too and as long as I've made albums
that way up then well that's good that's
a good way to look too yeah yeah
it's talking about starting at such a
young age with it came stardom and with
that came fame was there ever a rumor or
comment made about you that you just
thought this is ridiculous
well I mean you know anytime you put
yourself in the public sphere there's
always gonna be you know mistruths
half-truths people with automotives you
know and and so your trust meter meter
is becomes walkie especially at like
nineteen twenty twenty-one when you
first get into this and you meet all
kinds of characters and people that want
to work with you and you realize that
like oh there's there's something kind
of weird about this and you learn to
trust your gut you learn to over
communicate you learn to you know really
your spidey sense starts to get you know
a little more honed as you get older I
think that if 37 year old me could go
back and talk to 27 year old me a 17
year old me
I would certainly give him some words of
advice about just being wary of you know
of going against what your gut tells you
and but and I would tell that kid to
smell the roses a little bit some of the
success a little bit but yeah I mean you
know look I mean anybody can can can say
anything but I feel very lucky that I've
also been in a side of the business
that's not been like a paparazzi right
thing I don't feel like I'm being
followed I don't feel like the half top
TMZ vans are like searching for me there
are plenty of people with plenty more
things to talk about in this alev world
you know generally somebody comes up to
me it's like a dirty handshake right
played you at our wedding I feel like
I'm so lucky that I can sell I can sell
what I sell and still walk down the
street take the subway it's um it's a
it's a cool life it's you know what's
the fun is the whole Katy Perry thing
the one that got away did you talk to
her afterwards texted her a little bit I
was like really
she's like sorry I'm like no it's fine I
just might my Twitter is just blown up
today so thank you for that but yeah
that was a bit of a surprise
we were pals we've been friends for a
long time just she's great